as fire crews battle that fire many who
live in the area are thinking about what
to do if they have to evacuate and for
some with connections to the vegas
valley their next move could actually be
coming here arko mana is live after
talking with those who are bracing for
that impact orgo
well denise las vegas is about 450 miles
away from lake tahoe and the caldwell
fire is just southwest of there people
who live and work in that area tell me
they see las vegas as a potential
lifeline
it's been kind of like a freight train
the caldor fire continues to grow
threatening south lake tahoe and causing
evacuations in the area we live in fear
constantly and this is a nightmare david
pappas lives on the north shore of lake
tahoe originally from las vegas he moved
to incline village last year can't see
the lake
this is video pappas took driving along
crystal bay the smoke from the caldor
fire covering everything in sight
although pappas is still several miles
away from the flames he's preparing for
the worst we moved all of our valuables
out last week so our heirlooms our
possessions things that we can't replace
and he has a plan if the fire comes
closer we would evac back to vegas and
we just get a hotel room las vegas also
on the minds of those in lake tahoe's
casino corridor we're the home of the
command center eric barbero with the
hard rock hotel at lake tahoe tells me
firefighters and evacuees are staying
there right now and he says casinos on
the las vegas strip are already
extending a helping hand other
properties in the vegas market offering
to house our employees that have had to
evacuate it's just nice to know that we
have that as in the back of our minds in
the event that
you know something does happen where we
have to evacuate papa says he's planning
a proactive approach we are not going to
wait until the mandatory evacuation
order
fire officials say a lot of what happens
next with the call door fire depends on
the winds and those i spoke with today
say that's something they'll keep their
eye on reporting live tonight orca mana
8 news now